andrew how you doing i'm in canada right
now i'm in california
i'm in calgary calgary
i love calgary man i'm having a great
time i'm going to the repsol center
which is the local sports center a lot i
go out to banff i've been hiking i've
it's great restaurants people are so
nice they're very friendly
and they talk a lot
brilliant
so much has been made of the
transformation that jessica went through
in the the hours that she was in there
four hours to seven hours what was your
role in all of that did you ever feel
the need to sort of go in and make it a
little easier for her during that part
of the day i was on the chair next door
getting the same thing so no
what do you do what did what did do you
talk about the movie do you talk about
scenes or you both just sort of at that
period zoning out trying to like pretend
that it's not happening yeah it's like
5am till 9am and you're just sat in a
chair so like thankfully like the guys
that were that i was working with the
makeup artist that were
working with me we we had a really fun
time they were they were they were we we
just got done together and we just kind
of went star crazy and just just were
just saying stupid stuff to each other
for four hours we needed it
um and you know i i would have breaks i
would get up and walk around and i would
sometimes listen to music sometimes i'd
meditate sometimes we would just talk
talk it was like kind of
it became like probably the closest
relationship i had on set with was with
those two
burly dudes who are the visual effects
makeup guys who usually work on like the
predator
mask or like you know a an alien like an
alien coming in yes but like the on this
particular one they were working on
jim baker which was funny
you can't do anything lately without
people bringing it back to spider-man
and as much of a pain in the ass as that
must be how much of it is actually sort
of kind of wonderful too
it's sweet you know it's it's a
character that means so much to so many
people and me included and
it doesn't doesn't bother me you know i
when i i made those movies and i'm so
grateful that i did because it led to so
many other films and also i got to play
the character that i've always wanted to
be since i was three years old so
there's really nothing but love i have
for it and uh you know
and and i think that you know
the people who
who have who
who know my work know that that that was
a part of my life and then you know i've
i've been lucky enough to to share
you know live theater spaces with
audiences since then and when may maybe
those plays wouldn't have had the same
kind of attention that
that they would have if i hadn't have
played spider-man like maybe a whole new
group of people would wouldn't have seen
death of a salesman or angels in america
which are these great kind of like texts
of theater of the last hundred years so
i only feel like it enhances the rest of
my work in a great way
and before i let you go how much of what
you do is getting yourself out of a
comfort zone and how much of outside of
that comfort zone was tick tick boom
um
yeah that's i love that question and i
because you know you get i've been doing
this now for about 20 years and
you
you're always i am always trying to
expand myself in all my life in all
areas and challenge myself and take
risks and be
terrified and and tictic boom was
definitely an opportunity to to create
the next level of that i've never sung
before
uh and i've never done a musical and i
was so grateful that i got given the
opportunity for so many reasons which
i'll tell you about some other time but
when we talk about that movie but
it was a real it became this incredibly
important passion project for me so yeah
i feel very very grateful to lynne
manuel for um entrusting me with with
that character
um you are fantastic this movie is great
congratulations on everything we'll uh
we'll talk soon enjoy calgary you too
thanks
you